young lip Yakov has finally found a job
and is no longer one of the vast number
of unemployed young adults in Sweden
he's 25 years old and comes from Russia
he feels much better now that he has
something to do and is earning decent
money
he lives in Baku the capital of Conibear
county in southern Sweden the town has a
population of 80,000 a quarter of all
young adults here are unemployed that's
in line with the national average which
is higher than the European average Yann
lit via coffe took a course to prepare
him for the labour market
Stephan fluked works for a temporary
employment agency and he found leafy
akov his new short-term job fluked is
taking lip viacom to the seed wholesaler
where he'll be working in the warehouse
he learned to drive a forklift truck
when he was an apprentice at a building
Supply Company but that was not enough
when I finished I didn't got no job
because I didn't have diaper lessons
forget the drive lesson smile yeah you
must to have money it's expensive Alice
willing to get the drive lesson he'll be
earning the minimum wage 2200 euros a
month it sounds like a lot but prices
are very high in Sweden everybody wants
I have experience but how can I get it
if I can get my first job there aren't
many jobs for people without training
and those few usually get filled through
temp agencies flute says lift vehicle
got the job because he was flexible
when I was young you were allowed to do
a lot of things at the company but now
there's so much much insurance issues
and you're not allowed to do that and
you have to have to wear this and you
have to always work with him or her but
temporary work is not the same as a
career although it can lead to something
better
Riveter Mustafa sees it as a possible
solution she helps prepare people to
find work through the corner berg
project you can see that the
participants when they are in the
project they become more motivated
because they see the path they they can
see they way to work and education
through using different measurements
that we have within the project they
offer inspiration courses
it sounds esoteric but it's about
motivating people to take the initiative
these graduates are training as call
center agents but not everybody who's
been through the program finds work more
one--he some omar is a refugee from
palestine reefa to coached him for six
months but i still couldn't get a job i
don't have a driver's license and
without one it's hard to find a job six
six one day all but
staff at the government employment
offices say the main reason for the high
rate of youth unemployment is that kids
leave school without having learned
enough or at least not enough of what
they need
what's more vocational training is too
theoretical the sky's the ovule in
Sweden you go to school till you're 20
and that means you really spend most of
your time at school even if you're
training for a technical profession you
are still 60 or 70% of the time at
school like in the children when TR
bites Kiev and then north or as near
Mumbai I anger Bullen yun look via
coffees back to work but his job is not
permanent still the krona berg project
has helped him on his way and that's a
start